لكل واحد من هؤلاء الشباب حكايه مع
البطاله بعضهم انتظر سنوات ليحصل على عمل
واخرون استفادوا من خبرات غيرهم
فاطمه واحده من هذا الجيل الشاب تخرجت
اثناء جائحه كورونا وكانت فرص العمل حينها
شحيحه التحقت بدورات تدريبيه وطورت
مهاراتها ثم توجهت للعمل عن بعد تطوعت
كثير في المجال زي هيك
لو وصلت لمرحله اني انا لقيت فرصه اني انا
اشتغل وفتحت لي ابواب كثيره لشركات كثيره
شركات في السعوديه لغايه ما وصلت لمرحله
اني انا اصير كبيره في المشاريع الكبيره
هاي
الاف الشباب ينضمون الى قافله الخريجين
سنويا في قطاع غزه قله منهم يحالفهم الحظ
في الحصول على فرص عمل لا تتناسب مع
تخصصاتهم او غير مجديه ماديه في اغلب
الاحوال وهذا ما فتح المجال للتفكير في
فرص عمل خارج حدود القطاع في شركات في دول
عربيه واجنبيه وطور البعض هذه الفرصه
لانشاء شركات وسيطه توفر العمل والمكان
المناسب طبعا بحكم وجود قطع غزه قطاع
محاصر قطاع ما في اعمال
فرص وظيفيه هذا بتيح انه يحل جزء لو قليل
من هاي الازمه اللي بتواجه الخريجين
الموجودين في قطاع غزه
من خلال الانترنت من خلال العمل عن بعد
قدرنا ندرب خلال الست سنوات الماضيه الاف
من الخريجين اللي استطاعوا يعتمدوا على
هذا النوع من العمل كمص در رزق اساسي لهم
ومع ان عن بعد ساهم في توفير فرص عمل
لالاف الخريجين في قطاع غزه فان الظروف
الحياتيه من انقطاع متواصل للكهرباء وعدم
استقرار شبكات الانترنت جعلت الشركات
الوسيطه تواجه كثيرا من العقبات هذه
المشكلات تواجهنا من العملاء نفسهم بعدم
الالتزام بالعقود وعدم وجود قوانين تحمي
العمل الالكتروني بالاضافه انه احنا
منعاني كثير من الحوالات الماليه والدفعات
الماليه والالتزام بالنظر انه قطاع غزه
محاصر وهذه المشكله بتزيد بتتفاقم انه
الحوالات الماليه ممكن احنا ما نحصلها
باشهر كبيره وبتعمل عنا مشاكل كتير داخل
العمل
رواج فكره العمل عن بعد فتح المجال امام
الخريجين في قطاع غزه لمواجهه الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وارتفاع نسب البطاله لكن
خصوصيه القطاع المحاصر افرز التعقيدات لا
تزال الجهات المخ تصه تعمل على تدليلها
هبه كيلا الجزيره من مدينه غزه